walk out to this video playing Killian
from Italy and he's gained more than 100
points in the course of the last two
hours played him earlier but he was much
lower rated ok so I'm the Neo Philidor
try and form some early queenside
queenside player to know d 5 young come
on let's blast open the center while he
is a not too well coordinated night
Quincy similar problem ok so it's uh not
not doing much form for this year for
for the default square maybe that's
let's do this not spend ages him unless
it doesn't look too bad you cannot turn
really cancel long now he can cancel all
but not after capturing on c5 yeah maybe
long castles actually the movie
23 is also an idea trying to throw into
new text e5 with check yeah just think
maybe this one 'if i can play d4 at 95
maybe
at least I'm not terribly behind on the
clock
at this guy is a really good bridge
player played played him I don't know
countless times and you will see that he
knows something about the game it's a
really wide range of of players even
with 24 ratings there's so occasionally
you meet people who Joey just a mouse
artists but he's really playing good
chess ok so let's see what happens yeah
I expect long castles ok hmm now he's a
very good dynamic player i came i need
to castle no way to play without it oh
why is this even possible I thought I
know I can just take it just forgot
about this I can take it hmm
yeah anyway anyway I need to to open
things up here this is the the good
thing about my position I'm really
nicely developed at least a little bit
better developed than than he is okay
some night d 5 I can take these six yeah
tricky
I always have tempe on the Queen it it
needs a protective father you cannot
really give you five away i think 95
young yeah I cannot go Queenie to if he
goes here this is my BF five
I can do that if I go lucky 8 rookie 8f
[ __ ] hmm maybe I can take it I go f5
five quinte for the CAF occasion player
5 try to to win this
you can give the check on see form but I
can quit Quincy for check yes sir salam
I'm nicely developed I have good rupee
aid as a possibility Jack okay so rupee
aid okay that that's the right move no
doubt about it okay so and me too I need
to prevent him from canceling I can take
care of like winner for this looks
really good but this look I've won this
is a problem
um
maybe Bishop g4 is da is the solution
Bishop g4 also threatening rookie form I
hope this isn't just some [ __ ] move
I can play Bishop d3 m-maybe I should
have just taken for God's sake no I let
him out of this
yeah what a shame they can just kiss a
short gnome and this is out of it yeah
this i don't know i can please get the
poem back now I thought short castling
was much stronger ok gather still a
weakness him that's true yeah it is now
I had on the clock I'm such a kid he
never ever Jack should have gotten out
of this unbelievable and come there his
pawns are just more advanced him
time warning not sure about this isn't
this so bad it also needs some time to
get his stuff coordinated so also it's a
draw again only then i'm down on the
clock check check check
yeah Marcia it should have been a drone
again and now it's just black for this
on time she wanted to resign and then i
overstepped the time yeah i just bought
the winning position here no way this is
not lost for white absolutely no way
okay mother computer says is equal okay
very disappointing yeah this looks very
very dangerous yeah this is this was
another option but he's got work
everyone the only move to save him
otherwise its own but he's getting out
of it and this was actually not helping
at all because of Bishop d3 got here he
had short castle is much stronger okay
can turn this this I'm not sure I should
lose yea the a five point is very weak
yeah but now I was down below maybe I
should take a dig take your foils may
better hard to say yeah can't wait damn
it proceeded around here yet spoiled it
again to draw so of course i played this
like an idiot this you really should
draw us black less spend some and i lost
too many more CM a must-play g5 get my
pawn ahead I lost too many moves and I
actually overlooked this idea
this makes it much more difficult check
check check check quite surprised the
computer still assesses the sasal as a
draw maybe if you'll give checks on d1
instead of retreating this is probably
losing yeah this is probably losing but
what I don't understand they should I
have a good position here yet the King
in the middle and let's check this
cannot believe the sad d for looks nice
so maybe here he has something better g6
computer wants to play g6 with a clear
SH from black hmm they are very very
difficult this is not a not bad probably
not enough to to play for foreign edge
here yeah of course this is just losing
a move that it looks fancy but the
subspecialty 3 need to do this year and
this is perfectly all right something
like this it's quite nice for black and
the logical follow-up and now I got into
trouble also losing so much time in the
process I was actually head on the clock
yet yeah it's very interesting game
thanks for watching